Something has changed girl the
world's acting strange these days
the north and southern war
monsters roaming wonders should be hibernating
maybe it's the end of days
this continent was meant for no one
none of us will have any peace
until there are no monsters left in the world
that's my home my fight
your precious leaders after something
you're a pawn to get to it
rebuild our faucets strengthen our numbers
we are an empire the war's just begun
our best chance
are you ready for this
if what you say about that girl's
power is true you can't help her
we need your help fine but
gentlemen it's been an honour
What i made new friends get over it jealous?
Welcome back everyone toss the coin to your witcher
this is going to be my brand new witcher season2 trailer
netflix just dropped the full trailer
there's a bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i will
be doing videos for the episodes just like i did
for season one all the episodes the whole season
is dropping the week before christmas just like
season one did a couple years ago there's a bunch
of new characters that they're introducing from
blood of elves blood valves is just the next book
in the series that they're adapting for season
two there are a couple other things that they're
adapting from the video games to some monsters
but most of the story is from blood of elves
the title is a reference to ciri's elder blood
so the whole idea that they're trying to learn
more about her power people want her power like
they talk about emperor emhyr during the trailer
even though they don't name him and we'll also
learn more about the elves like there are a lot
more elves themselves on the continent running
around during the trailer the person narrating the
beginning of the trailer is nivellen you probably
recognize that voice it's Kristofer Hivju he
played tormund giantsbane on game of thrones but
you probably wouldn't recognize him in the trailer
because he's got his full monster makeup on all
these scenes of novella and him talking about
this giant war all these monsters going crazy
doing things they're not supposed to be doing
that's all from episode one the title of the
episode is a grain of truth and that's the short
story that he appears during it's basically like
a really dark version of a beauty and the beast
type of story with him and his lover vereena
the brooks that kind of vampire that you see
geralt fighting in all the footage and i believe
that's who geralt is seeing fly over the lake here
at the beginning of the trailer when novelland is
saying something has changed geralt there are all
kinds of vampires in the world of the witcher
higher vampires and lesser vampires the higher
vampires are capable of walking around during
the day when he talks about the north and the
south being at war he's basically talking about
emperor emhyr and nilfgaard trying to conquer the
rest of the continent they full on sacks cintra
during season 1 the war is just gonna get even
bigger as he goes around trying to conquer the
rest of the different kingdoms on the continent
this is a scene of geralt and ciri riding up
to nevelen's mansion where a lot of episode 1
takes place this is geralt's silver sword we
didn't see him use it that much during season
one he usually carries around two swords the giant
regular sword that he used for people the silver
sword he only uses for special kinds of monsters
and this is him inside novellan's courtyard here
at his mansion getting ready to fight the bruxa
vereena his lover she's a vampire thus he's using
the silver sword when nivellen is talking about
monsters going crazy roaming when they should
be hibernating they're just building hype for
the upcoming next conjunction of the spheres
talking about monsters being able to cross between
dimensions between worlds of the multiverse that i
believe this giant cityscape here is of nilfgaard
itself we see it a couple times during the trailer
this is the giant tree inside the great hall of
cairo morehead where they hang all the medallions
from the dead witchers that were their brothers
in the school of the wolf geralt makes the joke
to nivellen about how he's lived through three
supposed end of days and they're all crap he's
just talking about other really big events that
he's lived through the conjunction of the spheres
really is an actual end of days scenario when he
says the continent was meant for no one that's
actually a bit of a sly reference to the origin of
the world that the witcher mostly takes place on
but the idea is that humans and the elves here did
not originate on this world they came from other
worlds during other conjunction of spheres but
also it's a reference to the idea that the elves
have been beaten back by humans over time so they
themselves have become subjugated on this planet
and they're also kind of referencing yennefer
the other mages because it looks like she and
frangilla were captured by the elves after
yennefer herself was captured by the forces
of nilfgaard so like yennefer got captured once
during the battle of sodom hill then it seems
like they get captured again by these elves if you
don't recognize it this is arituza we haven't been
there in a while but that's where yennefer trained
as a sorceress this is yennefer seemingly reunited
with tessia unless it's a flashback of some
sort because the last time they saw each other
was at the battle of sadden hill where tessai
believed she had died you see her again later
at the battle of sodom hill right after the battle
like this is probably from episode one but this
is inside cara moran with them getting ready to
train ciri they kind of break up the fight that
geralt has with farina inside neville's courtyard
here when he's talking about none of them having
any peace like they break up this episode one
fight throughout the entire trailer when he's
talking about there being no monsters left in the
world he's also referring to himself like he said
none of them will have any peace no monsters
left in the world normal people normal citizens
within the world of the witcher also think of
the witchers themselves as kind of monstrous
this is from ciri after she's been at the school
of the wolf training as a witcher for a little
while and when she's talking about this being her
home that's just a reference to her thinking of
geralt and the other witchers like vesemir as
her family eventually that doesn't happen right
away but eventually she begins to think of them as
her family and she talks about taking up the fight
herself so obviously they break up the footage
like this scene of her talking about wanting to
fight and then her grabbing this order from two
different scenes like when she's grabbing the
sword that's from like day one of training like
what is this what do you want me to do with this
sword cut to a little while later when she's
one of the most badass fighters that they have
the really cool thing about ciri is that even
though she never takes the witcher potions to
fully become a witcher she does train like a
witcher and become just as badass a fighter
but the thing is she doesn't need the
witcher potions to make herself stronger
she has all that elder blood power so technically
she is the most powerful person within the world
of the witcher the most powerful person on the
planet it's just that she's so young she doesn't
know much about her powers so she doesn't know how
to use her abilities yet the reason why they have
that lion roar sound effect in the background is
just meant to be a reference to the lion of cintra
her grandmother queen kalanthi who was a badass
in her own right when yennefer is talking to
fringilla about their precious leader being after
something she's talking about emperor emhyr trying
to get ciri back and i feel like this is probably
one of the most spoilery aspects of season two
us learning more about emperor emhyr and his
backstory if you have read the books if you
played the games and you know what's going on with
this character please don't post spoilers in the
comments below because it's meant to be a really
big reveal like the show is probably going to play
it like a really big reveal for people that don't
know what's coming i wouldn't call him the main
villain but emperor emhyr is kind of like one of
the biggest forces one of the biggest antagonistic
forces on the show he leaned very large over what
was happening in present day during season one
also in the flashbacks technically but he was
going by a different name during the flashbacks
i don't want to connect too many dots but
everybody probably knows what i'm talking about
for those of you that are a big fan of the games
you might not recognize these actors here but
these are two of the big witchers that help train
ciri this is lambert on the left and cohen on the
right just helping train her with geralt the
others like vesemir at the school of the wolf
another really good shot of geralt and ciri but
you have fringilla's voiceover talking about
them building their forces at nilfgaard like the
war is only beginning there's another white city
shot of nilfgaard with soldiers riding out this is
frangilla later in the season in all white walking
through their halls inside nilfgaard then really
big reveal this is the first time we've actually
seen ryan's during season two so if you don't know
who ryan's is he's actually one of the actual main
villains of season two of blood of elves but
like yennefer implied he's really just a pawn
for someone else like he's a pawn for vilga
forts velga forts is working for emperor emhyr
ryan's kind of does a lot of the same stuff that
you saw kay here doing during season one kay here
is also featured during this trailer too i'll
talk about him in a second ryan's is another mage
working for vilga forts using magic trying other
ways separately on his own to try and get ciri
back then geralt in the middle of another separate
giant fight this scene of ciri running just seems
like it's after girl tells her to bolt during a
big fight geralt's in the middle of a fight with
another nilfgaardian soldier in their redesigned
armor so this is the same armor that you see
kay here wearing later in the trailer when he's
talking to frangilla from a much different episode
but as you can see they gave the nilfgaardians a
big glow up people made fun of that balsack armor
from season one so much they're like okay we got
your note we're gonna change this we're gonna make
this a little bit better then this seems like
a really weird scene of everybody inside the
school the wolf getting ready to attack ciri when
they first show up going from left to right this
is cohen maybe eskel in the background here then
vesemir next to him i'm not sure who this person
next to vesemir is then right up here on the front
in the right is lambert again this is istredd back
from season one he was yennefer's lover at the
school of beiges where she studied at aratuza
he also kind of foreshadowed what was going on
with nilfgaard emperor emhyr and velga forts
towards the end of season one as well implying
that he'd also gone to work for them this actually
seems like it might be francesca fendobar she's a
pretty big character she's like the queen of the
elves also a powerful mage in her own right kind
of like yennefer and this seems like they're part
of that big convoy of elves that has them captive
getting ready to fight this giant monster house
like literally a house that looks like it's turned
into a monster then you see ciri riding with
yennefer on horseback probably from later episodes
after they've been reunited the whole thing at the
beginning of the season is that geralt believes
that yennefer is dead but just like they bring
jaskier back at the end of the trailer like okay
we need your help again well i guess i'll come
back eventually everybody from season one is
reunited strega bore comes back from season one
as well i guess he's gonna continue to be a pretty
big character you also see him with yennefer later
then i believe this is the first shot that we have
of triss during season 2 and it kind of looks like
she's also been given a glow up too like a slight
redesign of her character but she's wearing the
green dress she's also at the school of the wolf
and helps train ciri while geralt and the other
witchers are there helping train her then this
other woman who's talking to geralt about ciri's
power is another sorceress who he knows called
neneke she lives at a temple in a lander geralt's
known her since he was a little boy and he winds
up bringing ciri to her later to learn more about
her magic then like i said the other witchers
getting potioned up getting ready to fight someone
inside the school the wolf it seems like they're
getting ready to fight ciri and it seems like it's
all part of this scene here where everything is
flying around things are going crazy as if ciri
has unwittingly unleashed her power as neneki is
telling geralt if what you say about her power is
true then there's nothing you can do to help her
they also intercut this with the scene of yennefer
with stregabor crying out in pain as if geralt
won't be able to help both ciri and yennefer
that is a bit of a misdirect but the way they're
playing this they want you to think that yennefer
is going to have to save herself as well as ciri
learning to save herself as well and that's the
whole idea of her training that's why they're
training her so that she can save herself then
as a lot of you suspected they actually confirmed
this on the witcher's official twitter account
this is geralt and ciri fighting one of the lesson
from the games it's a really crazy kind of four
spirit that's featured during the witcher 3 game
so that's where most people remember it from then
they have the funny scene of him going to bail yes
gear out of jail he's got the brand new costume
his loot is broken and he makes the joke about
making other friends like what are you offended
that i made other friends as he says goodbye
to the mice in his cell his song toss a coin
to your witcher during season one turned out to be
a pretty big banger so we'll see if he has another
one during season two they did have him record
all new songs for season 2 but if you spotted
any big easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't
talk about during the video just write them below
in the comments i tried to avoid getting into too
many spoilery things because the book story has
been out there for a long time so we actually kind
of know where this is all headed they released a
bunch of other extended scenes a little while ago
i did videos for those you can click here to watch
them and click here for that new preview video of
spiderman no way home with all the new sinister
six scenes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and toss a coin to your witcher!